my talk will be divided into three parts
I will start from telling you what
what's going to be new for import then
updates for export and I will finish
about telling you how do we integrate
our system with ffmpeg library and how
you can use it to extend built-in
functionalities all right so import so
far we had pretty much two video formats
it was a VI in QuickTime we're going to
add four new formats and also extend the
two existing formats on this slides I'm
showing the new new lists that we are
introducing it 12.1 this is the list of
video decoders main mainly useful as
lesson as information that kind of
read-only list for you to know what
what's currently supported so this is
divided into formats and that already
tells us what what new formats we have
so a VA a bi was there before Matroska
is new mp4 is no OGG is new QuickTime
was there before and there is also
called video format I will speak about
this particular one later so similarly
to video decoders well actually let me
maybe show you what what we have here so
for mp4 so if I go to mp4 section these
are the decoders built-in decoders that
that's gonna just work out of the box if
you have a video file which was encoded
using one of this video codecs we can
successfully decode data from it for mp4
container for and we have basically the
same similar similar list for other for
Matroska we can do more than for mp4
for example so these are video decoders
we have very similar lists for audio
decoders again we're talking about audio
in this video containers so what I mean
by containers is is this a bi matroska
and so on you can in this file format
you can store video frames you can store
audio and you can also store subtitles
and finally the finally the subtitles
list it looks like that so only four
four formats support subtitles a avi for
example does not allow you to embed
subtitle track into the format similarly
OGG ok so let's look at what metadata
you can read from this video files we
have a two flavors of the duration of a
file one that we currently call
approximate duration and another one is
called duration the approximate duration
is as the name suggests it's only
approximate so for this case 231 seconds
but notice the the timing
you only need point point 0 to a second
to get it on the then compare it with
duration it's it takes longer because we
really have to decode come the fra count
the frames basically to get to give you
the exact number we can Rica writ
approximate approximate direction from
the header so that's why it's it's so
fast
but to get to give you the exact
duration of the video unfortunately we
have to do the hard job at add decode or
Nia try to try to decode it the frames
but what don't really returned
we just want a number so that's that's
what happens there is a meta information
element that that tells you more about
the video file so we can go deeper here
there are video tracks audio tracks and
subtitle tracks for this particular file
so besides the the the simple container
information that the container type
again approximate duration the bitrate
let's look at the video track for
example and here are the meta
information for each video track this
this video has the only one video track
so we have framerate bit depth color
space and so on we we also have an
information about the codec so this
video was encoded with a h.264 codec
pixel format and and finally the image
size so that's that you your your video
files right each frame is of the size 7
64 byte Ritter treatment alright
and very similar meta information for
for audio and subtitle so lets me move
on we have also separate elements that
give you the number of audio subtitle
and video track so in general you can
have multiple of it of each one of them
most of the time you are actually going
to have single video track maybe one or
more subtitle track and usually only one
audio track but as i said all of them
there could be more than one and this is
the main reason that it it was not it
there is there wasn't a final review for
this yet but if you look at other import
elements related to meta information
that we introducing we are returning
Association
so instead of returning how many audio
channels is in that mp4 file instead of
returning to we're returning Association
one goes to two maybe we make change it
if there is only one audio track we just
return to so that it would be good to
get a feedback from you what do you take
always right of association even if
there is only one track present in the
video file or or only if if there are
multiple tracks little association so
association always okay so that was all
about the metadata let's move on to
something more interesting the video
elements so we have a video element for
import that gives us the the prototype
of our video player so this is again as
I said this is a prototype so not there
are still some glitches but hopefully we
will see and hear something I guess you
don't hear anything
just to work before
all right I apologize for that it's okay
okay so well as you already saw that
there is a you know dot button from the
alga GUI right so then you can change
the volume and you can select the output
of the device but that's the same
behavior as we have in our audio GUI and
there is another button here which is
inactive for this video but this will
allow you to select subtitle and audio
track so let me show you another video
that you can this will be active so
before I do that I just want to tell you
that video is also a new constructor but
we introduced right we have image we
have audio as a constructor for the
object now we're going to have video and
for this video when I click on the on
this button there is a way to choose
subtitle track because if you remember
from the previous slide it had to
subtitle tracks right so if I if I
select that English it started
displaying subtitles in English
no audio or let me move on we are
experimenting with different appearances
of of the player so this is for example
our experiment with having only their
video frames displayed and on hover you
see that you can pause and play that's
that's what's coming in this or similar
form when it comes to the video player
now programmatic playback that's another
interesting functionality and for that
we are introducing a video stream again
if you are familiar with with with audio
stream this is this is quite quite
similar with the summary box you can
check some metadata information here and
this is all done out of course so you
notice that it just stores the file path
basically that's that's all it is these
are the properties you call ready apply
on that video stream and well one of
these properties is is called current
frame so here I'm showing you the
dynamic of a current frame and the
dynamic of a position and you can
control that with functions like video
play and and video stop image list
mm this element was present before but
we just improved performance and add new
efficient access to selected elements
what we what we call partial import so
first of all you can you can select this
one means I want a first video track and
then I want to frame 300 - 300 - you can
do exactly the same using quantities
with with unit samples because these are
treated as samples but also you can
specify a time range so say you can
specify from second tenth second tube
10.1 seconds but that just in this case
that just gives me the two frames
what's important is it actually we have
to be frame exact if you ask for
particular friends so look at this I'm
asking for the first 50 frames and it
takes only around 0.2 seconds but when I
ask for the last 50 frames of this video
it's almost 7 seconds you asked for that
you ask for the exact frames I have to
decode the whole file to get you the
last 50 friends so that's why it's not
linear access if you ask you from
something from the end we really have to
decode up to up to this point however if
you don't care about the exact frames
you can see you can use the
specification in seconds in time range
and if you do that we guarantee only
millisecond accuracy and we can easily
seek to that MIDI second position in the
video frame and it is basically the same
time whether you ask for the first 5
seconds of the last 5 seconds that was
image list the video data works very
similar and we are returning numeric
arrays that correspond to two image
frames and finally you can ask for a
duration of each frame and the partial
access is again the same moving on to
out your elements so we also introduced
out your import element and it works
similarly you can ask for samples or you
can use same time quantities to get
partial partial access for for audio
some formats we also support audio file
which is our out of curve out your
representation but then obviously there
is no partial access you basically
giving you access to the whole file but
it's it's out of course so it does not
take any memory and finally similarly to
video data you can get a howdy and
return for the inter tokens
oh let me move on it's it's also that
was no more recovery basically for out
your data subtitle elements currently
it's it's let's consider that this is
the first release we only introduced the
raw subtitles in a particular format
it's called advanced substation alpha
format it's kind of divided into two
categories first you get a header data
so that's how the header in this
particular format looks like it kind of
defines the style of the subtitles and
the format of the events and now the
actual text data look like that so it's
slightly pre-processed but other than
that you see that this is quite rows you
have to understand what this is and the
description of what that text really
means is here that's the format so you
have layer start end style and so on
that corresponds to this line okay I
said that I will go back to the video
format so what is video format it's it's
a it's something that you can use when
when your video is not in the other
format that we support so say you have a
TS video then well there is a good
chance that it's going to be support out
of the box we actually register a bunch
of extensions so we also registered that
PS is associated with video format so
you don't even need to specify that you
want to import this as a video format it
will just recognize it unless we don't
register extension you should still try
to you know force force the force the
format video format that there is a good
chance you're going to you're going to
be able to import the information what
with this is obviously this is
importantly format so it supports many
different video formats less
come on let's come on video containers
we decided to basically put everything
in one format so as you can see I can
import the default element here for
import is a video stream ugh I can also
import the audio data it all works but
this is important Li okay so that's all
about import let me now talk a little
bit about export for export we're adding
three new formats we're not adding video
format right so that's that this is not
symmetric and we extending the existing
tool that is AVI in QuickTime similarly
to import we also have this dollar list
for encoders and these are actually more
useful because you can use them as the
values for video encoding and audio
encoding options for export all right so
so say you wanna use generate mp4 file
and and you want to use a vp9 codec then
you have to specify the video encode it
goes to leave GPX - vp9 and this will
generate mp4 file encoded with vp9 codec
and same for the audio format so now let
me start from showing you how to export
video frames only to a different file
format so first of all given the
manipulate text a manipulator expression
we can rasterize that the manipulate to
get a list of frames and then export
that to a video because I don't have
much time left I'm just going to show
you that the final result that's the
the mp4 file that I generated from that
manipulate I can do that the same thing
for image list so I've imported
multiframe TIFF file and basically
export at least to mp4 the list of
frames also video and video stream so if
you import the video object or video
stream you can pass it directly to
export and again it will work and what's
nice about it is it's all gonna work out
of course you have to have enough memory
to store this list of friends that you
wanna export but if you already have
video or video stream which is which is
out of core you can convert it to a
different format using using export and
it really doesn't use any of the memory
it's it's it's it's all done in in the
background using out of core
functionality okay you can finally do
video + audio into a single file it was
not possible before so say we have the
same manipulate but I'm gonna generate
the two seconds long audio using
hydrogenerator
and then using this syntax so I'm
specifying that my animation is my
manipulate my audio is is the argue that
I just generate I have to use that rules
syntax for export and I'm specifying
some more options for how to convert
manipulate to the list of images and
then it will just work it's it's going
to generate something like that and it
does have audio it's it's a pity that I
cannot really show it
you know it doesn't work
okay and finally obviously you can also
import list of export list of images so
what I'm showing here I'm taking this
six seconds long list of frames from
movie and I'm also extracting the same
corresponding audio and then exporting
that these two objects to video and
again that some time getting six seconds
long out the video with with that audio
and finally you can you you are free to
to export only audio to these containers
they are the multimedia containers you
can store three different type of tracks
but there is we don't prevent from
exporting only I'll go to this format I
want to mention quickly about the file
convert function so that that's the nice
utility that you allows you to convert
or what we call call it here it's
transcode a1 video from one format to
the other using default setting right
now we do not really allow you to do
some fine-tuning if you really want to
fine tuning then go from import followed
by export then you can use all the
options but here using the default
setting it's gonna do is gonna do let me
just evaluate this it should not take
longer than 30 seconds or so to convert
this mp4 file to too much moscow and
it's it's it's all working out of course
so it basically uses the default element
of import which is in this case video
stream out of core objective as it to
export using default settings and
got finished and we now have the we now
have the video in a different format all
right so the last section I want to talk
about here is limitations and what you
can do about this so you are as you
already know we we use it as a back-end
the ffmpeg library so all of I just
showed you here is it was possible using
the ffmpeg as a back-end we also use
different backends that is media
foundation on Windows and ap foundation
on on Mac OS however even with that
because some codecs are patented we had
to disable them so we cannot really ship
them with with Mathematica and there are
videos out there that you won't be able
to import that that's the one of the
example I have the excerpts from the
Harry Potter movie in the Matroska
format here it says that it's h.264
codec well to show you something if I
try to open this in QuickTime it's going
to tell me this so we're not worse that
the operating system right operating
system also cannot handle that file and
well going back to that list of video
decoders so I showed you before we have
this number is no you probably don't see
it it's 54 entries in this data set
right now these are the list of decoders
that we support out of the box for for
for but rasca however if you have ffmpeg
installed on your system and you can do
that we right now we experimenting only
with linux and mac OS so on on on Ubuntu
just call this line or
and it should give you ffmpeg on your
system or on on Mac OS we support
homebrew so just that line should should
install ffmpeg for you once is installed
we will try to use it without even
asking you it's just if it's possible
for us to load it successfully we will
do this by default and there is actually
a setting for that you can you can
disable this behavior using that system
option but what I did is hopefully it's
going to work so I I now I'm trying to
use system ffmpeg which I already have
installed there was a 54 decoders
available right now I have 237 and when
I try to play this file now it works
right because it's using everything that
ffmpeg offers you all the codecs
out there are now enabled alright I
think that's it I just want to mention
that there are two other talks this
afternoon
on video but the other was the one that
shall shut is going to speak in a few
minutes and then there is video
processing analysis talk do you have any
questions
what we have a yeah I didn t have time
to talk about this we have a compression
level option for export which is
basically converted to a betrayal but
yeah it's just zero one right yes well
right so you can actually do something
like that with the video strip there is
a current frame that you can access from
video strip and that well the question
is how do you write this right I mean
you could actually you could read frame
by frame using video stream we do not
have a functionality right now with
export that allows you to to basically
open the stream and right play stream
it's obviously it's available in in our
internal functions we have to think
about this but probably there should be
a dedicated factors for that we should
not extend export because that's like
what one shot right now that so the
function that that should yes okay I
don't think we have time for more
questions so let me you can ask me later
thank you very much
[Applause]